[Applause]
three-point story in this game 8 for 24
Portland 8 for 24 oak City and Damian
Lillard believe it son Damian Lillard
for the hack looked like the ain't got a
lot of contact on that good skip that
Park listen Aminu down in the corners
two-man game was cancer long three and
their calls Dame whoo Dame Lillard hits
another bomb order he said a couple of
threes this one from deep and the
Blazers six Lillard for three again he's
got another one another big third corner
in the makings from Damian Lillard and
here Adams you got to be up now you know
his hot game just comes to a beautiful
stop rises up in the second file former
teammates here very good for all what a
pic by Damian Lillard he poked it away
right to himself he throws it down yeah
look at this he comes meat win it throws
it
great hands by Lillard and he goes up
and dunk you don't see all the Dame dunk
too much yeah look at this he comes me
twin throws a great hands by Lillard and
he goes up and dunk you don't see out to
Lillard two minutes remaining in the
third quarter and Lillard has been the
star of stone he hits another one
add to the total for Damian little him
hang on this shot I mean great defense
by shrewder but just not enough